anyway hello to both chats and hello to
my chat as well yeah hi everyone in
Eric's chat I'm guessing people who are
watching you are cheering for you and
people who are watching me are also
cheering for you because that's the way
it usually goes in my channel it's hope
so yeah I mean they have to cheer for
the underdog right yeah do you want to
tell people a little bit about the
format yeah sure so we're gonna be
playing a first two 20 wins the most
important rule is that I have to
sacrifice a queen before move 10 which
should be interesting
you you can sacrifice your queen
whenever though it's more than welcome
thank you I just wanted to clarify that
on my end yeah
so first first two 20 wins will be
playing 10 blitz games to start out and
then the rest of the games will be
bullets and yeah it should be it should
be interesting have you prepared at all
or you're just going on to it give you
that information
okay mr. Rosen let's hoping to have some
some secret Intel but I know I'm not
gonna say anything let me keep it all in
here okay fair enough
and we are going to be playing for a
$500 prize fund we're gonna be splitting
it 70/30 so you know at least we're
gonna give Eric something for his really
sad not a valiant effort to be should
see you and my friends momentarily
oh okay trust me uhm Chesapeake and I
also start the first game for us
oh sweet okay perfect all right so I'll
talk to you later
okay fine everything you know bye good
luck meeting myself okay all right
thanks everyone for the supports all the
new Suggs let's let's focus okay this is
my my first opening prep I'm gonna try
the Aman Hamilton gambits unbeatable
opening I think this is the best way to
sack a queen hopefully you got two
pieces for it
I mean Bishop f4 is a main move I'll be
disappointed if she plays something else
and then just trades and then waits for
the Queen sack I'm very happy five
hundred dollars I'm not sure talkie
it could be someone anonymous or it
could be a combination of donors yeah
this is actually really nice this is a
triple fork I feel like I feel like I'm
on Hamilton right now now this what if
she if she plays Bishop c3 Bishop before
Queen d2 takes takes okay she's playing
Knight c3 so I'm very happy with this
cuz rookie you want I'll take on c3 or I
move six are you I have four more moves
to sack my queen there we go
Oh Tess gambit number one and I'll take
here starting like c4
oh let's develop I was squad stream did
she accept my I sent her the invite but
maybe we'll work on that later I have to
stay focused there's money on the line
Amman Hamilton actually played this in a
st. Louis Invitational Tournament
against Steven's ER with black like raid
a feed a rated game and almost drew they
got to like a table of a strong position
and a four-four kind of scary let's be
safe I'm on eventually lost in like over
100 moves I want to put the bishop here
dark sorry Bishop is actually quite
quite nice in this position
III is weak I have ideas 95 yeah
maybe night 95 anyway need Bishop here
I'll develop I'm trying to align my mind
bishops with whites more powerful pieces
c5 may be coming but c5 I can take it
now f5 ideas a5 is a major threats I'll
so I'm up a a minute this is good start
mmm I 5 immediately I have time to think
here I mean at 593 I promise of white
wants to play a 5 to be a little bit
cautious
not if I doesn't work mmm I could do
this she looks reasonable if this I can
take it I think at this point it's just
about not getting mated for the next
like minute or two I still want to
playing out of five it doesn't quite
work
maybe this move I grass would move yeah
G choose a target at five is still a
threat I'm also dreaming of like meeting
along with rook h6 eventually oh oh
there's so many moves oh this looks so
fun let's play this move because now III
is attacked and I'm preparing the rook
lifts with hopefully eventually
checkmate c5 ooh
c5 okay I can just take that
I'm still dreaming of this hmm okay D
files nice there's a lot of nice things
here play this move okay now I have
ideas of meeting all this could be so
nice I'm threatening Nate in 1 2 3 let's
take a pawn and then here
oh no that hangs and nights oh wow she
tricked me but I have this move and then
this move ok life is still good now life
is very good I could take a pawn
oh the rook was hanging but Knight is
powerful let's play c4 toss pawns meant
to be pushed I know she is fast she does
play a lot of bullets well then go for
mates oh let's take a look ok ah let's
do this move ooh wow ok takes and then
takes and then where's my mates this is
a move okay Wow okay that was a good
starts happy with that
it shows the score right here so it's 1
to 0 let's play okay I'm gonna play III
this is part in developing ok this is no
longer opening preparation wood bit I
don't know what this is it's moved 3 I
have to sack the Queen somehow I could
turn the meat with Bishop c4 but if I I
can't meet before I sack my queen
okay I'll develop I mean the goal is to
get like two minor pieces for the Queen
but I mean g4 okay I don't want to take
too much time here as well I was hoping
together rook for the Queen okay I think
I'll do this in a second b7 and then
I'll treat it like a hippo kind of
Bishop coming here upon coming to d5
okay let's be a bit more solid she's
playing very quickly
okay I have to keep up the pace so I
have a queen for a bishop or I have a
live a bishop for a queen not the best
trade ever I've might see six ideas this
could be nice yeah the thing about being
down material is I think sometimes you
just have to pretend you're knock down
material and try your best 96 I have the
option here I think I will play Knight
c6 even black at SAC I'll have a rook
for the Queen another thing about being
town material you just don't want to
trade like that much so it probably
makes sense for locked
maybe sax on something back okay my
knight is doing work at 95 so I'm not
trading got away with winning upon there
I don't like f4 soon yeah
I mean I should probably avoid trading
again play this move as I'm sneaky maybe
I can attack like the previous game mmm
that's a good move
I could play g3 I don't want files to
open maybe i5 that's playoff five and
this is another strategy is just keep
the position as close as possible I'm I
think I'm happy with this I was just
moved to idea at six
mm-hmm promise c-4 is coming don't play
this move first I'm trying to be
flexible and then II for most likely
before it's anti positional but I think
it's necessary 94 well it's what you for
I know c4 will come I'll just try and
weather the storm
yeah let's play a g4 soon before let's
put the Ohno and let's not do that let's
do this first
in c3 as possible hey I won Kinect for
this is gonna be a time scramble but I'm
not so disappointed in the position
wow what a position look at this
position she wants to play Bishop g5
preventing Bishop g5 my whole my whole
Queen side is gonna fall it's kind of
sad mmm let's play this
oh dear okay I'm losing a rook play this
move there's still attacking potential
though kind of don't play off six never
play off 6f6 just kills my whole attack
okay
that's also difficult to deal with takes
takes takes g5 do I do it I'll do it for
the emotes
yeah we're trading yeah this ship goes
back
Brooke here whoa it's it's bits this g5
bits this is difficult long time please
maybe three yes when the Queen back the
counter votes a scam it go in ooh good
move I'll try and stop the thing yeah
still me
ah this checkmate wow what a game oh I
had my chances that game good good game
boat s it game well I won the Queen how
many times in this match boy I win the
Queen don't think it'll happen too often
well the game
okay do I repeat the same opening not
sure
g3 smart move let's play mmm I see six
okay I have an idea I'm gonna say take
on on b2 with the Queen uh-huh
she doesn't let me let's move five I'll
play this move the very least I can take
on he too waiting for the night to move
oh she's gonna play d3o d4 okay let's
play yeah Queen takes e - coming I feel
so wrong to do this so wrong if I did it
each five okay Queen odds time let's
play let's play a five a four I can just
Castle I'm trying to be solid Lulu can
move play Knight g4 if f3i Fork
Wow Connect four
but I have an outpost string the Knights
I mean I have some squares to work with
maybe bring the Knight to f5 again time
is very relevant I'm gonna try and get
up on time I have an outpost it should
be for interesting well I could no I
can't take twice because there is a pin
but the bishop also defends my planners
rooked Yeats and then takes let's start
with rook to e8 watcher take on g6 if
takes on g6 I fish about five and end
trapping the Queen who takes first I'll
take with rook ooh the grass would move
what did you I mean I can probably make
sense to take first ok sneaky threats
well she wants to meet me oh let's play
this move and then this move my bishop
defends well position still feels kind
of solid I'm down a queen my Knights
pinned to the h8 square should be three
oh good move did this move my Queen side
is crumbling attack the bishop I want to
win the pawn maybe maybe take first it's
with night
hmm why not if I first keep the tension
idea in 93 also g3 is weak it's gonna be
another I feel like it's gonna be
another time scramble interesting let's
take this what comes to the fifth Frank
I'll be very happy takes and rookie -
okay I have I still have a night for the
Queen but I have lots of counterplay
this is looking nice Rick do you want
prevented rooks defend each other even
though clean attacks both rooks pawn and
boots thanks for subbing okay let's
attack Wow if this move just have to
watch out for counter play but does this
take stakes let's pin trying to win 38
mm rook t3 again this is nice Queen Oh
Queen check I move here threatening this
yeah Knights pinned
Oh where's my mates check where's my
mates looking for mate I could take this
looks so fun I'd have three coming
plenty of time I can take here oh look
at this mates oh it's not me yeah the
Queen defends from a distance but oh she
didn't wait that's not me oh this is me
okay Oh
Queen takes g2 as possible but um okay
two two one that was nice
III kept pieces on the board and got the
attack eventually let's play this again
she's not giving me
fun stuff h4 win bits the wing bits
thanks for the win bits hmm no this I
should have done more preparation in
this phase cuz I'm not sure how to sack
my queen maybe I should get the dark
squared bishop mm-hmm thinks people I
should develop let's develop okay I'm
sacking my queen like this oh she didn't
take it
wait I tried to sack my queen I I want
the bishop not the Knights um I guess I
can do this move ten is approaching I
really tried there okay I guess I'll
sack it for a night
this is move nine well that's so sad I
liked how she premisis she pre moved
Bishop takes c6 I knew what was coming
okay let's play this time is very bad I
spent way too much time in the opening
phase okay let's play this move I'll
push a pawn again I don't want to trade
pawns trading pawns will open lines and
this is this applies to any position
where you're down material you just want
to avoid open lines keep the position
closed the bishop here and she's going
for the tack rightfully so i king h2 g4
is a weakness g5 on g5 good move let's
play
they this move I mean it looks so
grotesque but maybe I'm I mean I'm kind
of this is my bomb shelter
don't play the bomb isn't strong or so
strong but okay I'm still defending 94
trying to avoid the trades you see for
coming
connect for just got here you can see
the score right here so it's two to one
I do have light square control my nights
are relatively happy 95 eventually
afters covered I mean it probably makes
sense for her to play rock up to
Limerick g2 I'm very happy with my
nights also this is probably a really
good move but one of the issues it's
easy for black to just be materialistic
so hold on to all the material and with
that approach that you can be harder to
find plans
all right look I've won but I'll have to
trade off a pair of rooks okay let's
play this move along with the king
d4 now let's play this move maybe a 5
and she's seeking time know it's hard to
find a plan for luck
oh that's her plan mm-hmm it's hard to
find a plan for me to probably just have
to wait I'll try and discourage a six
draw okay
why play-fi myself I got the diagonal
now let's do that we'll tack this is
gonna be a dance-off like neither of us
really have plans but now okay she's
doing something on the queenside
Oh Fork okay the fork Knights has
emerged I'll take and then take here I
want to do this in this that's hard to
do let's do this move a five keeping the
time advantage let's play this move okay
open file I want to play rook f1 so I'm
working both sides of the board
I'll good move what you do I bring the
rook back let's bring oh I have a knight
Knight check not sure what that does
didn't do anything
play this move I'll dance around for a
little bit ooh kini what is this later
smooth transition to the Queen side I'll
play this move
Oh skewer Oh and fork now my bishop is
strong I don't want to trade that off oh
but there's rook takes a five okay tin
plates okay pass pawn
over the queen sac okay okay
survives all right I'm building up
confidence building up confidence I was
funny of that game she's in tears take
my queen the first time and kept the
bishop
what's the playing it's not f3 all the
time starts running it's 96 leads h3 the
hyper-modern lafawn oh it doesn't take
it what's okay I want to UM just take it
okay fine I'll take it oh let's play
this okay hippo time brace yourself for
the hippo yeah okay so guaranteed close
position she's gonna do stuff let's
undeveloped avoiding trades with all
costs three interesting okay read Zavala
hmmm I think it would benefit me if the
diagonal opens this is like the whole
point of why I wanted to trade the Queen
for a bishop a smart move
well okay I'm fine also closing the
position I'll probably play a c6 and
yeah my bishop will be sad but my king
will be cozy any eights okay I think she
forgot about this move yeah let's
develop a castle yeah what wants to push
pawns hmm yeah b4 is coming it's very
hard to stop an e4 b5 so let's play c6
and just whether the pawn storm thanks
for the Sun far far far
welcome back for three months let's play
Bishop to c4 outpost for the bishop so
what's material oh I have two minors and
two minors for a queen that makes me
slightly happy let's play lyric b7 or
carrying double-up good move play this
move it b5 I can take it I think c4 bad
Oh 95 oughta move okay at least I'll get
the d5 square for the Knights
ha this is difficult though and b5 so
strong I'll play this move my minor
pieces are not really doing much apart
from this Knight forgot about that I
have this move on developing again I
want to take the pawns a week
let's see four is gonna fall at some
points Brooke Burke b7 I have to trade
interesting
there is a queen bee fives a threat
Queen B 5 rook c7 as I've rook not sure
what to do here like King age 7 any 5
yeah mm-hmm h4 this is difficult
I'm trying just have to create like some
defense some fortress like 97 and
everything defends everything that's by
h4 I only get a night off for in the 93
yeah that move hurts me play this move
it's still alive
okay I'm going for the King side attack
because what else to do yeah okay should
be seven this is terrifying please take
up on AHA let's play this mmm oh I can
take this and I lose a thing I have to
go for this okay tricky idea uh check
check
let's try this and then g4 and Knight f3
I'm so close to meeting but not quite am
I getting made in here I think I'm
getting mated house it's so sad um
Bishop here only try
hoping for stylename now aha another
queen
how many queens you need uh I'll check
know how the pong is pins oh I guess
that was technically a queen sack at the
end okay
good game botas is it oh it's three to
two okay so I still have a lead
I mean the games are closed like every
single game
there's no Givens to change at the
opening a little bit I like this idea
though how she's countering mind you
whoa it's mop rail with bits okay let's
play this move thanks so much more peril
5,000 bits
well let's not get distracted I have to
focus
g4 I could take the thing immediately
let's play in s3 mm play well maybe I
can do this stuff let's try this stuff
move six and thank you a squire is 94
subbing she's not giving me any counter
play um like g5 I guess I'm trying to be
aggressive trying to orchestrate some
kind of Queen sac
I probably should take ya taking upon
takes there's not expecting that okay
we're gonna have a post set up again I
lost several Tempe moving my queen but
it's hippo time I five five probably
good move its castle play did this move
preparing before okay I'm just trying to
be solid I have a knight for a queen
have all my pawns yeah I don't want the
position to open up a five good move
let's play okay let's play this move
trades are coming they're very hard to
stop I'm calculating takes takes Bishop
f5 Bishop g5 what's the boat s candids
Lotus gambit is when you sack a queen
for questionable conversation there's a
Wikipedia article about it I think this
is uncomfortable let's play a four idea
of rook lifting her on on him
thanks for so Eric I am not here very
often but love to watch your content oh
thanks so much welcome to twitch yeah if
you're just joining I'm not interacting
with the chat too much I do appreciate
the new subs oh but we're having a match
I need six preparing it's very hard to
defend the pawn actually another strong
move c3 okay I'm gonna play c3 it
gambits a pawn but maybe my rook will be
happy on the open files
I think it's better oh that's a good
move - whatcha do takes and before as
well let's do this first this move
okay so I have initiative I attack the
bishop in the pawn if the knight comes
here I'll attack both these pawns
ah I have this move okay I feel some
momentum to watch out for ninety three
and my three really hard to stop both of
them should move the bishop
there should be three down a little bit
of time Rick do you on coming oh this
this position is much better than it was
a few moves ago mmm yeah this move I did
before or bishops III played before
first question the existence of the
night all good move aha
okay Ricky - yeah I lost a pawn I want
to win this pawn though another good
move Bishop c4 coming now the king is
actually a little bit unsafe for black
I've uh I've a bishop for a queen bishop
for Queen and pawn but two bishops
white squares we idea this this and then
this and then this
check ooh
let's start with makes you five takes
takes oh it looks so fun I've heard you
sack so many pieces oh I can't resist
like g5 coming mmm check oh look so much
fun where's the meat though I'm almost
other pieces okay idea Rick h1 h1
they are there let's play push me - ah I
forgot f cheese hanging don't meet me
there don't me me no yes she's so fast
open I'm faster okay oh well the crazy
game I was crazy position I thought I
had meat but I was getting mail it
almost but then dirty flag okay fortune
- so we played we play ten you play ten
blitz games total yeah so this is our
our seventh blitz game and I can do math
and the rest will be boy games
okay she's tilted looks like well does
this move let's play this move well it's
my first time oh she's doing things it's
play in this Muji oh thank you
only pong she's giving me so many moves
in a row I don't know where my queen is
going but it's gonna go somewhere
Thanks taggi and thanks lonely pawn lay
twin bits the late win is better than no
in um let us move anyway maybe I'll sack
on f2 oh I have idea never mind
she's in play she's confusing me okay I
have to take enough - very soon it's
interesting like she's not letting me
sack for any pieces so I'm gonna have to
sack for a pawn
Wow not even letting me sack enough to I
guess I'll play Queen 86 oh no my queen
she didn't take it though
wait what let's move eight what do i do
how do i sack my queen for something um
c5 I guess okay because White's not
grabbing space I guess I'll grab space
I'm sure there's a random people on
chest comm watching this game and not
realizing the nature of the match okay
now I can take the thing let's play lacy
for first idea to play this in this
there's already like light square
conversation and whites not fully
developed
before okay let's go for the kill
I wonder if before is a mess up because
b3 it was more intuitive let's castle
let me do this
okay check hmm
I mean this Bishop is almost as strong
as a queen right you just have to get a
Knight to e2 let's move back that's good
move and g5 when in doubt play g5 v e5
and I'm fighting for his face White's
pieces a little bit questionable play
this move later I'll play f5 try and win
Connect four
oh she wants to try my bishop hey there
I mean okay I'll start with this
deserving Bishop e7 interesting
I could play e4 yeah II for cuz now if I
for I take on g4 otherwise I want to
take and place an Ivor Bishop on e4 yeah
I've had a few games where it's been a
bow test gambit declined but I basically
forced I force the boat s gambit upon
the boat s okay I'm feeling very happy
like White's pieces I mean the sorrow of
whites pieces brings me happiness
what should you I mean things are
defended
a five and six
not sure you always playoff six I think
ideas to play rookie six okay time is
very relevant there's about five
yeah I'm not trading G for tricky hmm
I want to play off five soon hey she had
her chance to play off five down a
little bit of time very close position I
could trade queen is infiltrating oh
this is uncomfortable
the night was hanging for a while their
house this is very uncomfortable she's
playing very well
Oh No ah what do I do
you still may me ah
wow I was feeling good and then man she
she went full beast mode okay I'm still
up 100 that's so disappointing
especially with the way the opening wins
ok d3 again mmm okay I'll prevent g6 mmm
she might still play g6
and now now I've prepared her in the
opening this is great
I'll play quick moves she's using same
strategy
unfortunately so the idea is to sack
here mmm
hey this first let's move six
play this move hey okay yeah let's do
this
this is nice I'll play the hippo again
play a three and a ch3 trying to keep up
the tempo each for idea h5 and then rock
h4 rock lifts mmm that's like f4 there
should be five is a move also this is a
move Bishop e5
there should be five Ola trades at some
point okay yeah yeah let's push a beep
on idea night b3 okay time is good pawns
defended its by tagging you can do it
thanks dougie let's play always play
Bishop that flowing Oman oh my pawn it
wasn't actually hanging
let's bring the rook back yeah good
maneuver what's my plan a for I guess I
should've seen one oh good move
mmm that hurts to do this move
yeah now this is unfortunate all the
pawns are falling oh my gosh oh that's
so bad I mean I'll try and survive my
only hope is time okay let's play this
move play Bishop here aligned with the
king and the bishop idea rook c1 I just
have to pretend everything's okay Bishop
a3 played this move she's playing extra
safe it's probably good strategy oh good
move
ooh interesting I have I have this move
I just moved two things are heating up
let's do this move idea to play 96 later
ooh the counter boat s gambit what does
this takes I have to not trade too much
I should have won
mmm play this move skewer well it's
getting weird again
defend the Knights and this is really
bad for me but outside chance of hope I
have to believe in myself
play play this move down so much
the thing like I think that was a smart
decision to sack the Queen at the right
time I can take this oh this is still
interesting well maybe it's just still
bad for me take stakes
let's take here have lots of Clare
bishops mm take here oh oh not getting
needed yet I don't think
oh good move ah stalemate me please
please please please tell me me crazy
rook let's go crazy rook I have to be
careful though
check crazy rook check how crazy Brookes
not going to last
oh that's so sad ah crazy rook died I'll
free pawn which pawn
no I got me the Wow such a close finish
- good game late
well they came off really fought I had a
crazy rook it didn't last though go Eric
yeah kudos - so I bow ties for seeing
the stalemate trick yeah I think even
objectively the physician was was lost
when I had the crazy rook okay so we
have two more two more games play you
six this time also thanks for the bits a
KD 707 let's go for scholars meets ah
she saw it oh let's play this move
mm-hmm
let's move five and I get the most for
my queen oh that's good move I'm gonna
have to sack the Queen for a pawn
it's second f2 I'll stock enough to so
pawn and rook for Queen and night the
problem is like some trades so could
simplify the bit okay night C for ideas
good move
okay I'll while the trade so to bishops
in to rooks
that's gonna be quite difficult always
play off six some g5 ideas hmm I'm pawns
are smiling who takes takes what b5 I
think in this case because I have extra
Brooke I do want like an open file to
work with everyone I'll play rook c8 I
am looking forward to bullets yeah it
should be interesting and bullets going
to be a mud throwing fest
um I can castle never too late to castle
connect the rooks close down the
position I could take two maybe I will
take I think I could take though them
takes on c4 okay that's something rook
is coming through a 93 I Bishop d6
there's tactics I have to be aware of
though what they work on a 4 rook still
has influence that's a good move
so I have to take and play g5 the bishop
here you can take on a - let's put the
bishop here first
I wanna play see it I'm fine repeating
you were k3 let's play this move some
idea of Bishop g1 hmm maybe for not
seeing a clear plan I'll swing the rook
is why not that's when the other I still
have time time advantage okay I don't
want to take play what to do play g4
turning this
it is getting interesting takes takes
yeah I really don't want to trade what
to do though you got seven I'll just
leave the tension see what white does
before let's do that ooh
drop the pawn okay put the rook here
okay free bishop that's still scary
let's push play this first draw no draw
what's a pond Oh what did you so bad
goo free Queen thanks the protest
counter gannets always nice to see
okay well the game what a game
oh man stressful rematch this is the
last one yeah this is this is the last
one
a blitz first uh first 220
I only have five wins I need 15 more
wins to win the match
now there's a whole arts of playing down
material come back this the come back
come back okay
happy minute thanks for the bits let's
play let's play new opening c3 and
smooth mm-hmm yeah let's play this move
I don't know what I'm doing though um
play this move I'd yet to take a night
Queen d6 well I can't I can't trade
Queens oh this is so confusing
let's bring the Queen I have to where it
came from
if I trade Queens a sign of protest
candidates and so sneaky
we'll develop a night one mu5 a few more
moves to do so mm-hmm okay my dears to
do this in sack or queen C to even do
you auto forfeit we did not discuss what
the realm of what the consequences are
of sacking or I love not sacking I guess
it's honor system play this move I just
want to take a night please let me haha
take my queen
I did tell her as we were planning this
match I told her that if I leave my
queen hanging she has to take it
okay so Queen has been taken yes I have
a I have the dorks for Bishop this is my
my one prized possession Alfea and how
to it and hopefully it will flourish
I'll bring the Knights and this is my
square as pond controls c5 and this is
scary-looking pawn chain doesn't make my
Bishop on g2 happy what are you doing
I'm playing a match where I have to sack
my queen within the first ten moves I
know there's probably a lot of people
joining that are just confused apologies
for that
mmm Castle queenside maybe I'll play
I'll play a four before is interesting
I'm scared of this move but if it
happens I'll deal with it this move also
very scary if not not three I'll play
King D one
okay let's develop
I'm staying flexible I don't know what
side I want to castle on in my plan is
Knight c2 and be solid time is ticking
when time is ticking it's always a good
thing Brooksie one gypsy three yeah just
kind of building my my fortress mm-hmm I
don't see fives coming but I have to
deal with it
Oh see fives coming extra strong okay
I'll play this move I'll have might be
five two might be five she doesn't even
love me okay yeah I'm just trying to
hold my grounds also scary oh this is
gonna be so painful that's such a good
move okay I can take first
counter-attack the Queen whoa father of
God I saw you on Alexandra math quote as
streamin do you played botas gambeson I
came here to see once so much father of
God appreciate that um let's play let's
play this move by 36 seconds okay I
can't get distracted have to stay
focused it's probably not a I mean maybe
will she take the Knights yes we'll see
ooh good move
let's take here I gave away my prized
possession oh good move mm I just want a
castle and not getting needed bad move
f3 okay solid move yeah oh no c4
she didn't play c4 that's good let's
play rook c3 all about time
[Music]
this is really bad no don't make me use
don't 11 seconds Oh dirty flagging
coming under for much nights
yes dirty flag it's a draw
oh what a game as a dirtiest flag of the
match so far Wow five and a half five
not four now isn't me Aloha Bowl it
games coming up brace yourself for more
dirty flags oh my gosh I need I need a
small break you smell great
oh I am playing like a turtle I was
trying to play like a hippo yeah I mean
the position was very much like some
kind of tortoise my shell was completely
like destroyed but dirty flag okay
so how do i oh she just got a chest
Comrie oh okay
mmm things are getting interesting
channel thanks for the entertainment
yeah thanks thanks to everyone for for
joining and and supporting um dad we're
gonna have a lot more chess with with
one minute I can't take too much time in
the opening I should just stick with
like some I don't know what I should
play you go just play like III Queen
here and then sack whenever I got the
chance
how will Eric know how to sack his queen
without a time for expert level analysis
I'll try my best
it's gonna take more focus so I want to
play England gambit but she learned her
lesson from the first game don't mess
with the England it's unbeatable
there's no ultra bullets I think it was
just one minute did you prepare for the
match I so I prepared a little bit okay
she's challenging me well the best in
rows in tea thanks so much
father God okay time starts now you okay
I like close positions French structure
she's a French specialist but that's
okay
playing your French anyway didn't move
play this move this move yeah I'm being
attacked I don't like being attacked
ah
trying to hold on oh this is so
unpleasant let's play this move good
move
mmm
what's my plan well this is so so bad
one mating idea this and then now it's
not going to work okay I got needed Oh
five and a half all oh that's rough it's
me really rough okay
rematch I have to stick with hippo I
didn't stick with help of that that game
it got difficult sick with hippo
okay I like the structure mmm or do i
maybe I don't
and now I do again
each five good move
I'd get some maneuver the bishop here
and try and trap the Queen moon for town
for town let's go oh good move let's
play King f1 okay I'm gonna keep my
Bishop Bishop super-powerful let's play
not sure what to play mmm unpleasant
leave this move I want to win the clean
back there's a d5 yes let's win the
Queen okay
Louisville game ah I didn't win the
Queen play this move don't make me
I'm turning beautiful mates rook g5 made
an end rigged age seven yeah check and
then meets oh that's not meets for win
Queen takes air aah oh no do I do
take that let's go
35 also winning position oh this is
gonna be messy okay young children close
your eyes if you haven't already London
Wow let's get rid of the London Bishop
let's take let's take a bunch of times
good move Castle just stay calm
mmm
not sure what that night is doing ah
okay let's take okay I'm something
things are defending each other by four
minor pieces
play this move
draw free queen thank you okay
hey thanks for subbing yay yay okay just
have to play quick moves
it's very hard to deal with the checks
yeah okay yay let's go seven half so
five and a half
don't mess with fo let's play another
hippo all it starts like this
yes okay this is what I wanted
oh let's not take the rook it should
more powerful than your hippo time
hungry hungry hippo I'll connect for a
freak lon
it's next forward destroyed Oh F before
coming at for a good move
let's deep breath um G for I guess this
move I must move align with the Queen
hungry hippo let's take this hungry
hippo also many arrows let's take and
fork mmm I too strong to trade off let's
play this and then this I for aha good
move let's take up a thing I'm this move
I have a rook for the Queen and some
plums mmm good okay
life is good life is very good yeah and
game time Jack
i trapped overnight almost trapped g6
good try let's go let's go oh that's not
meat where's my meat there's me okay
somehow oh she took to u6 I guess okay
Eden have five and a half hungry hippo
will will be continued hmm how she knows
what I'm doing
Oh nuts okay this is nice this is just
what I want now Ivan the rook - I don't
think I'm even worse or down material
because I got a pawn for it hey let's
move Oh pin him in pinning win ah
doesn't quite work mm-hmm almost works I
like the position though oh let's take
and then pin and win well she's not
meeting me good okay pin and win okay
time is good let's castle oh let's not
castle h5 Connect for a three Oh
okay Oh trying to stay steady now this
idea of taking on e7 or g7 is quite nice
this is my favorite new opening idea
it's not efficient oh thank you
peppermint biscuits ooh
on this week have to defend it play this
move yeah the tack is coming I have to
brace myself oh let's play let's play
this move training open the file 95
ideas this is so scary
that's why f4 mmm okay things closed
down let's attack the pod
defend a pond kick a knight defend
another pawn always play Bishop f1 rooks
you want open file mm-hmm let's play
this move plans hanging of but this
one's hanging and defend this pawn
attack is gonna be scary though Bishop
g4 ship g4 h5 let's do this move ooh
good move or is it good enough attack
two things defends everything play this
scary position I just hung a bishop
let's take this again complicated
what c7 defended no I get it made it ah
oh I'd like my position kind of rematch
nine and a half to six and a half
oh no adoption yeah I don't think we'll
see adoption but I guess it's still
possible play the singling gambit again
Oh what is this take take care I don't
want trades new trades hey let's move b5
coming before okay punching time
nice double fiend hello let's defend and
not trade yeah the whole the whole idea
is don't trade anything um no that's
good move
yeah she wants to trade let's play this
move okay defend attack take a pawn
mm-hmm defend everything no more traits
play Bishop b5 oh she's attacking let's
move again
take a pond efile cluttered okay I can
take leave this move first
mm I don't want to trade but I have to
not looking good on the fork doesn't
even work
let's check her g7 oh no ah no I'm
getting made it again I like my position
again - what should you I had to hold on
got on focus
okay good thing this is unrated nine and
a half seven and a half we gonna start
with B 3 B 3 B 3 E 3 Queen G for a
bathroom break okay now I have a what is
my break my break is to stretch my hands
say hi to the checks you called oh yeah
I turned the heel off cuz the heat makes
sound okay I'm taking a hoodie break
I'll be right back
okay who deactivated
we're playing to 20 wins
I've not in half you can see the score
right here I'm sure people will keep
trickling in and asking some night I can
explain chat people can explain move on
one one cansada thanks so much 20 so
every win is a point so yeah 21st to 20
wins 20 points it's been it's been
intense so far I mean this game what did
I do wrong in this game I was playing on
instinct like this position seemed
really good and then I was scared about
the f7 square I should have yeah I
should have just taken I should have
gone from material because I could win a
rook and end
oh you've not seen any teeth this was my
mighty is a little bit left it's
actually mushroom coffee it's for sig
Matic it has a lion's mane helps focus
but I also have water because hydration
but yeah so far I mean I think it's
going better than expected why do I have
an arch icon on my cuff on my coffee mug
this is not my coffee mug this was this
was here before I moved into the chest
bra cave so you have to ask the chest
bras oh yeah my secret potion I mean
anything with like with caffeine can
help to jimster is studying my openings
and they're supposed to be good you know
the yeah uh yeah don't don't copy these
openings I'm fine well okay the hippo
I think the hippo has been serving me
pretty well it's been it's been an
opening that like just keeps the game
going long enough so we can get to the
dirty flagging face is it really a bow
test Cabot if it's on purpose yeah this
is one of these like philosophical
questions that I don't know if I'll ever
know the answer to okay she's back ooh
game starting III so preventing g6 mmm
this is gonna be difficult to sack my
queen Oh what do I do
okay not a good opening I'm in a hippo
hippo time at least attempted hippo
I was very unpleasant a four in each one
yes II four very strong I'm take maybe
maybe 495 yeah
problem is my whole queenside is like
still stuck
this is unfortunate I want to play d3
please let me play d3 mmm not sure what
the plan is
you have to sack back so I'm just down a
full/queen in this move
I have Connect for my one hope outpost
I'm really hoping for the counter in bow
test gambit no don't hurt me
yes tell me about you scan it let's go
yes Wow I was getting meat it I think
[ __ ] slipped but I'll take it's dirty
very dirty game very dirty okay
a turn in the house yeah it had to be a
mouse lip apologies for the the trauma
that my opponent just experienced so its
first 220 so I have 10 and a half yeah
the rest of the match will be bullets
yeah that Mouse that may have cost some
some money there or maybe it was a pre
move what's the slow okay no slow-motion
replay attack of bishop
hmm tricky idea Oh free bishop it's it's
before move ten - I'll take this very
happily take that and now I'll sack for
night okay so we have I have two minors
this is nice let's not take anything
just yet MMA 594 interesting move not
sure what to do that's probably good
move play this move this move okay crazy
stuff happening oh I dropped a piece no
mmm so bad all the opening was so good -
oh wait there's hope a little bit of
hope still rookie five to be five please
please home see it how the opening was
so good what did you next game so I'm so
up by two yeah c5 was probably a bad
decision on my parts yeah rook sefa I
was hoping she was pretty moving Queen
takes d5 that's life
no this opening again let's bring the
Queen back around hippo time
mmm let's play this okay close position
hmm a for Wow f5 wouldn't move let's
play c3 she's playing well I won't play
rook h1 she's playing very well it's
hard to to deal with lyrics eat one
oh no play this move it's interesting
Jack
very little hope here
ooh well I'm still knowing time ah oh no
okay I went for dirtiness but I spent
way too much time yeah she got faster
she got stronger too okay play this line
again
Lucy seven hangs it doesn't take it try
and trap the bishop
I hung do six but you have to count on
the fact that she'll get me stuff I want
to go for a pinion win okay this is
actually feeling kind of nice hmm lyrics
e6 r 9h eights some rook h6 idea
what to do check okay when the what's
happening here take a queen take a rook
okay she gave me everything that was so
generous
it's like Christmas and birthday on the
same day okay
for a brief period of time okay I'm
being aggressive hog jam
let's do this move it's move six let's
take a thing
let's move seven I still have to bow
test gambit at some points it still move
eight I'll move ten I'll bow test gambit
yeah okay
Queen sax back I died once so much
material there maybe it's still my
birthday and Christmas I'm attacking
stuff take stuff just have to be careful
with this position I counter-attack the
Queen c5 to move there's a smooth this
is my winter palace oh good move
mm I'm losing back material I'll still
have oh no I only have a rook for the
Queen I thought I had more I guess I
pawns you have lots of Hans this move
it's not so simple though
hmm
oh this is bad no let's try them in the
pond yes
a dirty flag oh I was a rollercoaster
game oh that was a rollercoaster game
man yeah apologies for everyone who had
to witness ass
move 500 I'll take the the Knights oh I
want pinning win so badly it doesn't
quite work yet please play have five
there there there that's castle still
doesn't work please
yes pin and win I was waiting for the
moment oh but it's dull I'm not winning
anything I did not win let's play this
move
hey passed pawn open file
Oh I hung a knight mm-hmm tricky move ah
she saw it play this move fork don't pay
me use Oh Mamie please have mercy
have some mercy
oh I got needed I really tried it was a
time scramble okay I'm down by two also
Nicola gifting a sub - ISA nibble
thanks to Cola yeah I have to figure out
what to do yes okay whoa whoa Nicola
gifting greeting 10,000 bits calling
thanks so much Nicola thank you so much
but I can't get distracted I have to
focus on playing moves Oh Nate was
trapped
that was almost trapped play d4 okay I
really have to stay focused but thanks
again Nicola oh let's play a nice move
no sacking everything I've so many
pieces for the Queen shall I drop the
Queen on the play room cheat - lets play
this move
ooh I'm scared
okay skewer time Oh
let's take okay now we have a chess game
take a pawn take a look okay let's lose
anything okay
being extended 13 and a half please let
me take it please no take on F to know
how nice off the Queen move seven okay
Mike Fork let's take a night do this
move is it a six
mmm yeah I'll take him take on e5 it
looks risky but it's Castle that was
really bad he knew seven I just move I
want to play e5 so I want to actually
sharp in the game play you for one chain
I have this move might win a piece it
might not though that doesn't win a
piece of this move why should i fade
first what to do let's play what do I
play here King
see the smooth
defend okay defending down a lot of time
though okay let's go some hope no lost
stuff whoa it's my pearl with bits with
5,000 bits you still make me ah dirty
flag dirty flag thanks so much for a
good omen bits Wow dirty flag to Queens
deep on sheltered my king for just a
moment there oh I can almost hear her
rage from miles away
oh I was so so dirty
yeah it's scary for a white cuz you know
on stalemates you're also long time
okay fourteen to eleven oh she did she
yell and tell her to take a deep breath
actually don't give her too much advice
okay so we have I have fourteen points
to eleven points let's play more hippo
hippo time I want to sack on the square
okay I'll sack here I'm at three
aborting trades take a 4 wou chest me
breathing thanks Jess we've shallots a
weed um if you're just joining I'm a
little bit preoccupied I'm down the
Queen I'm playing bow tez free Bishop I
enjoy that oh let's play Bishop e5 soon
let's go for the four mmm okay I'm
trying to trap the Queen
it's so pretty free queen let's take a
look first okay everything trading also
rook is hanging pawn is hanging I'll
take a politic the room
yeah I'm just simplifying everything ooh
okay let's take okay what a game
yeah I have 15 to 11 let's go let's play
this gambit again all this thing again
this move it's funny move what is this
woo i sack a clean a mile ah am I
allowed to win it back yeah she could
have taken with pawn I can win it back
okay I think that's like within the
rules sly boots has Gama did but she she
played the wrong move to take the Queen
Oh
let's move the rook back ooh okay oh I
lost a pawn let's do this Connect four
it's still actually a fight you know
she's playing very well maybe it helps
not having a queen cuz then you don't
have anything to blunder except other
pieces my pawns doing d4 oh that was a
blunder ah I feel I'm overconfident cuz
I'm like I won the Queen and I'm down a
ton of time
don't know okay this is maybe okay push
up on Queen the pawn I could promote
tonight's but I don't see how that wins
check draw oh no I got me that no I saw
Viking she ate oh my gosh
oh she beat me with the counter botos
gambits oh maybe that's that's her
secret weapon oh that hurts so badly I
think the fight it should have been the
draw if I played kingi eights okay stay
focus deep breath you know to try and
avoid yelling I have a 15 15 15 to 12
play h3g for yes I'm not going to take
the row it's a really manage time so we
have a thick kind of a hippo type
position who didn't want to trade the
bishop
okay that's life closed position playoff
three new for the Knights good move play
this move threatening to win a bishop
and the Queen play this move
please oh don't
yes okay almost pre move rook takes a
five out of instinct
ooh forgot that rook was hanging okay
it's still a fight
let's take in this kind of five I'll win
d6 hopefully or not let's take that mmm
it's not pleasant
okay listen Knight c3 take the rook in
the 95 check whoa it's almost mate I'd
f6 we'll need legal move Wow I'll bring
the knight back jack okay this move my
Knights defend each other such
friendship nothing over this hanging Oh
but King the textured rook okay I'll
defend the pawn
objectively let's check Wow Mikey and
seeing game ok 1612 still takes work
even when I win the Queen back ok let's
play footie 5 again fun opening play
this move take a pond I still have to
sack the Queen at some point play this
move I should have taken the bishop ok
I'll take this way we have to treat
bishops played b5
okay ooh scary scary there there there
it's okay yeah it's really scary though
play each five now things close down my
knife is completely stuck this is not
gonna be easy
Wow move that's such a good move oh wow
I forgot about that
hanging so I'm about to get needed
let's turtle up turtle time oh maybe I
can promote
mmm doesn't quite work I was trying the
rosin trap but I was too long time okay
13 to 16 I need four more really I just
need to play one more and stay focus
focus focus
oh good move it speaking d1 b6 defend
this is unpleasant this is really
unpleasant
it's do this move okay still down a
Queen h4 o gonna move it's still kind of
alive another good move
I've see four after placing four and d5
oh this is so ugly
well I'm threatening rook takes g7 stick
on g7 first okay comeback time mmm just
keen b3 no there goes my thing aha ah
it's brutal brutal okay
14 14 to 16 it's gonna be close I really
have to stay focused
she plays d4 all I'll play the England
again she plays g3 trying to think of a
way to be sneaky England time ooh I can
take
hmm muevate okay c3o let's play this
move first the e5 Center is opening up
good move
oh let's not trade ah trade anyway
don't play rook see to check the a5
mm-hmm okay some alignment with the King
some g5 ideas no no stop it stop it
take here oh no that doesn't work I'm
getting smaller made it no wow what a
game
Congrats to bow tez I got some other
made it and I was so unfortunate I was
like a real Queen sac okay one point
match
these moves coming in like bullets okay
I like the the structure very closed
she's sacking and move more sacking Wow
oh that hurts I forgot that's double
check okay
still some hope ooh free queen I'm only
down the exchange we're down there
Brooke I'm down the rook okay mmm I'm
almost getting needed to which is
unfortunate
I see four oh no I cannot to go back I'm
just made next move this is so
uncomfortable
huh Wow it's tied sixteen all okay I
really have to stay focused opening has
not been going that well
she's been dealing with my openings
okay 60ml
the structure she played really well to
to break through though I should drink
some water okay and the handicap is that
I have to sack a queen in the first ten
oh she didn't take it
ah oh that's so bad this move we traded
so much oh no that's so so bad
let's try and drop the Queen mm-hmm I
only hope his rosin trap oh my gosh I
just lost all my pieces this is so bad
he still made me g5g five ah oh my king
is being hugged by the white pieces okay
17 points I was so bad because I could
have taken on Dee to bloom yeah she's
she's prepared to lose probably
memorizing all your Queens Act lines
seven okay of Hippo comfort zone
I want to double on the C file
let's keep expanding
I'll bring the 96
she'd not see the Queen's attacks she
saw it
play this move
okay coming back complicated position
plenty of time though very complicated
let's take and go for meat
okay revenge
it's 1717 very very close
let's not plunger this time just woke up
I did last say 44 hehehehe okay thanks
for that I'm gonna try and be solid open
the G file play this move
push it H pawn okay two bishops two
rocks trying my best
you can't really take can I take that
takes takes clicking b8 first that's
what my plan is
mmm okay we'll do this
oh no no wow good finish
oh man I'd like the position to I should
have taken on g2 earlier eighteen
seventeen hi Eric I was just checking
are we playing first to 20 wins or 20
points wait what's the difference
like draws oh I just assumed 20 points
yeah like geologists gives us both half
points okay well just checking all right
yeah you later okay see you okay uh yeah
twenty oh yeah twenty points
I mean I think that was implied but okay
let's go
I really have to stay focused
let's take here and then bring the
Knight to d5
your time is very relevant
you pick steaks not the worst thing ever
hmm okay close position what is this
what is this this is weird all the
action shifting to the Kings side
hmm this is so terrifying if this move I
have this move first
okay oh I forgot about that
so bad okay interesting
let's go dirty flag 35 okay
18 18 oh man I should have lost that so
nice plate checks I think like the king
should have walked to h5 that was
probably the dirtiest yeah had my pawn
to save me leads go eat school
yeah with a game well the game I know
she's yes are cool down after that's
okay let's um go back to hippos stuff
this move how do I sign my queen here
move six after sack it for the night
hmm not good okay we close the position
play f5 be aggressive I mean that 4g5
okay Kings Indian style go seven nh4 to
stay defending
this is interesting move let's do this
move free Queen thank you
free bishop very nice so generous sneaky
move okay yeah there's the one still me
chop it then they're morally okay eat
Scoob one more I just need one more win
one more win come on No Mas no mas
okay let's try and stay focused place
quickly probably hippo hippo gang hungry
hippo afford the money yeah some game
she's playing really well it's hard that
other games I'm able to hold on until
time gets low
okay so much tension okay my hands hands
are so cold
okay all comes down to this where it
might come down to the following game
but what to do okay be three again this
move don't mess with the hippo don't
mess see this movie
okay I'll take okay hippo time have no
time is she trying to flag you in RL I'm
not sure what that means
okay let's be solid by 5:00 coming let's
win this ho ho
thanks people I assume those are people
could take take 66
it's risky she's scared of g4 okay good
ooh bad stop waking up three only move
well she has rock takes out five no o9f
for what a move look at 9:04 fork I'm
pinned in both directions but she's
forked I don't know what's going on okay
f5 again let's play this move I'm losing
stuff stop taking stuff f6 always play
off six with a BAM f7 coming play this
move every time oh good move so calm
let's play I want to play this move
no mr. run no no no no don't maybe stop
it stop it no I got I got me that Oh
such a cool game okay that all comes
down to this
wait Otis hey Alexandra
quick question yeah it's not win by two
it's just whoever wins the next game
wins right I mean I think that is what
we said yeah that's that's fine son
death okay can we can we can we take
like a minute before we start uh yeah
sure that's fine okay okay thanks okay
meditation meditation
Oh lux love play some meditation music
okay
takes
okay
play that's life Alex a shot
mm-hmm Oleg's trapped
oh ye oh no it's not trapped I don't
know I didn't see that
hmm we're both being safe okay fork town
let's go
let's go
no that's so bad soccer queen please
please please please
no I flags Oh
the game what a game oh what a game I
tried some so hard what a match match
all the final I I have a good position
before I lost everything all right I
have a reasonable position maybe around
here what a game
good job bowties yeah can get an F in
the chance what to do oh I think
stalking no I know I know some people
including myself are in denial well it's
my prayer it's MacRay oh what an amazing
performance by both players thanks so
much for Farrell Wow I I appreciate that
I'm still in denial
oh she plays she played really well
though it's uh especially under pressure
here cuz I I had so many pawns inside of
rook time the light came in yeah I I
cracked I shouldn't have taken us six
Wow a Nicola Wow Eric cheer will 10,000
oh my gosh thank you so much everyone
appreciate like so much support I need
what to do it's some really interesting
I mean I know if interesting is the
right word there were some dirty games
there was some
I mean there were some interesting
positions like matter of getting
compensation and I really tried I did
try does this mean the boat s gambit is
no longer considered sound I think it's
it's probably now considered slightly
dubious and it's such a close match like
thanks AKG 707 yeah what to do some some
games to analyze maybe a book on that
match oh no it was fun though
it was fun I took it pretty seriously
like I was trying to be as competitive
as possible while chess bay also things
chess paid for helping us start the
games hi Eric hey whoa hey hey
congratulations yes it was intensive end
I did not yeah no I I think I was
getting like super confident when I was
like three or four ahead but then then
you started playing you're playing very
strongly and quickly too and like some
of you some of your attacks were just
unstoppable well that is good to know I
mean there's definitely some psychology
behind playing when I know I'm a piece
up that was ya know like a gesture but
you were doing so well
I tried no I think in the beginning mass
oh well thank you I've been studying the
the games of nerd its key and and root a
hey no I think in the beginning you were
playing too conservatively and that hurt
you because then the games were just
going on too long at some point I
realized you have an extra queen might
as well like attack open the position
and not be afraid to like sack
well that's true that's true my child
was telling me you were you were maybe
having some difficult moments with those
dirty flags
I I was I was surprised at how often
I've been getting flagged I think I've
played more Blitzen bullet lately and
now I'm getting a little slow again
are you gonna continue streaming by the
way um that's a good question maybe for
a little bit I was gonna do sub Sunday
but I need food I'm gonna probably get
some sushi first so probably not oh I'll
be back later just for the did you
prepare anything for this match um kind
of so I I was drinking mushroom coffee
which is supposed to like help me with
focus and concentration in terms of the
test in terms of the chess aspects I I
had an idea of some openings like I knew
I was gonna play the hippo for the most
parts there is actually a tournament
that I played over the summer I taught a
chess camp and I joined the tournament
with the campers what I had to give
Queen odds to all the campers so playing
that helps me kind of know how to just
keep the game going long enough to to
get the dirty flag got it got it but
yeah i was really just hippo and the
england's gambits
which worked the first game that's a
pretty tricky line actually then only
three girls say you are so fast and you
don't hate it
alright well thank you so much for the
match I was really impressed yeah I know
it was it was fun I think people enjoyed
it I know there's this pretty large
audience for this and congratulations
again alright Eric I'll let you go then
thank you so much yeah I'll let you go -
take care you as well bye bye bye
okay people I think we're gonna wrap it
up I guess I'll put this on youtube I
don't know what I'll call a YouTube
video if I won I would call the YouTube
video eating boat Eze with the boat s
gambits but now I don't know I'll have
to find some other alliteration